(light electronic music)
- [Host] This is Jubal,
an Eastern Black Rhino.
Coming in at around 2,690
pounds, big is an understatement.
But with less than 740 left in the wild,
the Eastern Black Rhino is
one of the rarest rhinos
in the world.
Jubal is 20 years old and
stands close to 12 feet long.
They are solitary animals
with an aggressive disposition
to discourage predators.
They may seem tranquil,
but they will charge first
and investigate later.
Black Rhinos are browsers,
and eat leafy plants,
branches, shoots, and
whatever else they can find
in the highland and Savannah habitats.
His large ears can
rotate to pick up sounds
from many directions.
Today, Eastern Black Rhinos
are only left in Kenya and Tanzania.
The population has declined by 90%
over the last three generations.
The biggest threat for
these guys are humans,
as poaching has absolutely
devastated their population.
This is the Eastern Black Rhino.